I'm marketing fundamentals faculty chair
and simply learn presenting programmatic
foundations in this course we're going
to cover the basics of programmatic
advertising what it is and how you can
make it work for you
programmatic at its core is automating
the buying and selling of advertising
media using technology if you've gone to
Google AdWords and you've set up an
account and you've developed ads to be
shown for a specific search phrase then
you've developed a programmatic ad you
have creative and you have established
that it will only be shown upon a
specific trigger such as the search
phrase you've automated the display and
the trigger of that creative to be shown
to a user who shows themself to be
relevant in looking for what you have
that's the basis of programmatic is
automating the system of buying and
selling ads using technology now you can
use this system for branding to increase
your reach and awareness for a campaign
specific objective also we are most
familiar with retargeting that is
putting an ad in front of a user that
has been to your website we can also use
programmatic marketing and ads for lead
generation we can target them to display
on a specific device to go in a specific
channel and we can also use those
campaigns to develop existing customers
by presenting customer specific
campaigns based on their history their
purchase history or specific campaigns
based on a characteristic programmatic
encompasses a wide variety of media
usually when people think of
programmatic they think of display ads
the banner ads are the rectangle ads
that show on a website when you go to an
any news site or content site display
ads are part of programmatic you can
create a creative to show in those spots
and bid in order to put them there
that's one of the primary ways that
people use programmatic but you can also
develop rich media to display in any one
of those areas and define at which point
a rich media ad will show instead of a
static creative you can also define the
channel so that your ad displays in a
user's social feed and you can target
specific people based on characteristics
and have your ad be presented to them
just specifically in their social theme
you can create a custom audience through
Facebook where you take your own
audience you upload it into Facebook and
you can target your users utilizing
Facebook and present a custom message to
your users you can also develop this and
bid on video to be shown to specific
users that can be shown as a pre-roll
video ad when they go to youtube or
another video site or you can even bid
on that video to be shown to a user
within the context of a website that
they would go to in this example we see
a video ad from Microsoft playing on
forbes.com because it was a specific
user that was targeted to receive that
information and the advertiser Microsoft
has also bid on the ability to put a
video rather than just a static display
ad part of programmatic is also focusing
on the device that I can show ads
specifically on a mobile device or
specifically a laptop or desktop based
on what I want the user to do ads on
mobile right now are performing at a
higher and
rate then ads on desktops or laptops in
fact mobile ads have an 18 percent on
average click-through rate which is
higher than desktops or laptops what is
really doing well in mobile is mobile
video consumers are watching a massive
amount of video on their mobile devices
and so ad revenue in the mobile video
arena is estimated to go three times as
much as desktop advertising be aware
because of the higher competition it's
going to cost more to bid on mobile ads
specifically targeted to users where
they will be in the content they are
viewing included in mobile is the
ability to buy ad space on apps app
developers as a different way or an
additional way to monetize their apps
can open up inventory for advertisers to
bid on ad space within the app that way
you can bid to reach people through an
app on their device through their social
stream and you can determine which type
of ad they can see in any one of these
channels marketing Sherpa did a study on
advertisers and saw that their average
conversion rates were somewhere between
one and a half to four percent based on
the channel where they receive the lead
so search has an average conversion rate
of about almost four percent paid search
almost three percent webinars generated
leads but only had a conversion rate of
about up 1.6 percent social media almost
2 percent and a lead to opportunity
conversion rate however advertisers that
didn't just rely on the initial
conversion but followed up with
programmatic ad targeting techniques saw
an improvement of over 32 percent and
their cost per acquisition returns so
utilizing programmatic as an additional
layer
of using these advanced abilities to
target users based on their behavior
demographic characteristics or your own
customers based on purchase history or
history with the company you can enhance
each campaign and you can improve your
campaigns are using these targeting
techniques to meet people in real time
and what we've seen is that when ads are
delivered to people in real time based
on behavior that they just exhibited or
a site that they recently visited they
are twice as likely to interact with it
than an ad that is not based on their
behavior advertisers can bid to get
their ads in front of people in the most
critical time period of all and that's
real time immediately after a certain
behavior or a site visit they can
interact with those customers and get
the right ad the right ad media and the
right network to be in front of the
right user at the right time this is
programmatic foundations
I'm Matt Bailey thank you for watching
the introduction and I look forward to
seeing you and further modules
you